hello cette vidéo était en fait ma
première sont l'htc vibe mais à cause de
pas mal de soucis au montage alors
justement du gameplay audio pie x et
caetera et le temps qu'il m'a fallu pour
corriger au mieux tous ces petits
défauts et bats la deuxième vidéo est
sortie avant votre vidéo d'annoncé
suffisamment bien se trouve avec le htc
vibe et oui c'est un boîtier de réalité
virtuelle à dire de télé réalité mais
pas du tout sinon on l'aurait jamais
acheté et la particularité de celui ci
par rapport l'oculus et qu'il ya deux
petites madeleines comme ça sans fil du
coup on va pouvoir manipuler des objets
que j'ai choisie et wadi un jeu hors du
commun jobs simulator on va être
question est bâtard c'est pour ça que je
suis attardé à plus tard et ça faisait
neuf quoi bon j'ai ramené à 20 des
bulles ok c'est parti ça ok on peut
choisir son métier d'accord soit on est
dans la mécanique soit on aime soit on
est un chef de cuisine soit on entre
dans un bureau on va faire [ __ ] j'ai
toujours rêvé de faire un métier mais il
faut des grosses compétences donc on
savait a toujours été refusé alors donné
un cachet c'est parti on est il pas on
part totalement là dessus oh [ __ ] je
suis kessy avatar qu'est ce que tu vas
faire fermer ma gueule balance moi les
trucs à encaisser quand on sait qu'il
s'agit
elle pâtit frais repas auquel s'est
envolé ma vie c'est ça c'est met un
casque sur la tête et être caissier donc
il faut que tu y résister
alors il ya des caméras de sécurité
ah ok voilà la caméra est activée
bonjour comment ça va c'est pourtant
petit cadeau mon frère ok ça marche
alors je prends ton petit paquet le
code-barres et quelques pins ohlala
sa fin selon el pais la tête et tu vois
je souhaitais pas très vilain et moi je
parle bien avec toi j'ai pas compris ce
que tu as dit il faut aller dans le
congélateur de y avoir un congélateur
super y a rien dedans bien totalement
rien dans cet endroit il faut voilà on
va faire cuire en [ __ ] si fighter ce
mec je les tue pas la peine avant à
temps mais je savais pas qu'on pouvait
manger sa part contre la manger vit
actuellement ça n'existe pas encore
allez on fait cuire ce [ __ ] de
burritos par sa manche
c'est génial tu as fais ça tu te rends
pas compte mais il a depuis des années
ok c'est cuit tiens non moi je le salue
à je suis débile tête j'ai fait un bruit
tous pour rien c'est aussi ce qu'il
fallait faire le con je suis désolé
c'est mon premier jour ici j'ai beaucoup
de mal quoi et ensuite way est ensuite
logiquement voilà la ya les petits pains
et on va totalement en mettre un dedans
qu'est ce que vous faites je passe en
encaisse et je leur passe parce que je
savais à coeur c'est pas ça c'est
abonnés soit un aller de respect envers
des coups je fais comment après 106 al
green [ __ ] la barre à prendre ta
monnaie je peux vous rabattez relais je
ferai les saucisses grillées sont si
loin que ça c'est un problème que mon
grand père disait qui prend pas
s'abonner se prend une saucisse grillée
est excellent on adore l'humour
allez tu peux t'en aller [ __ ] je suis
con c'est le ses managers et veulent
virer la monnaie à tient à bientôt
et ben voilà managers sont à penser quoi
dire que c'était bien
qui dit pas que c'est bien se prend t en
avant des problèmes aujourd'hui c'est la
folie ok client suivant bonjour salut
comment ça va ok je te fais péter ça au
maire j'évite d'y voir une famille je me
deux fois je suis un arnaqueur
on va totalement la ruine et tu veux une
petite glace il ya pas de soucis
mouvement regarde je vais te prendre un
petit pot tu veux na kwa une à la une
bleue ok c'est parti où je vous assure
que c'est beaucoup plus fun de
travailler dans ce magasin virtuel que
dans un vrai magasin
tiens mange ta glace [ __ ] ok mais pas
en plus à fond il est pas con ça ça
c'est un client ça c'est un gars qui
achètent le magazine l'a 30 millions de
consommateurs
on a mixé de magazines différents c'est
pas grave on s'en fout allez tiens ah
non il faut que je mette faut que je le
mette cela pour le faire grossir au
alors là mon pote tu as peut-être
connaît une petite soeur ou si je
faisais mon idée là dedans excellent on
s'amuse on a dans l'humour au il a dit
il nous a dit garder la mauvaise il est
gentil on la caverne hacker parce qu'on
a fait passer six fois savoir au
chocolat buffer overflow price x 2 en
mer je me fais griller
[ __ ] magasin haut ils abusent de mecs
quoi il en fut partout suivant d'accord
si le ticket de loto alors yahoo ticket
de loto assez ça ok ok madame alors vous
voulez quoi ce magot la fortune dont
pour vous ce sera un jackpot
allez j'espère que vous avez gagné c'est
pour vous tu veux le vent la grand mère
m'a mis en avant à elle veut que je
gratte pour elle d'accord y'a pas de
soucis madame si je peux aider
par contre si c'est gagnant je garde ça
je vous préviens je suis parent
d'escrocs sinon et voilà c'est perdu ah
non elle est triste quand je suis désolé
tiens reprends ta moan et je te la pause
sur la tête c'est pas vrai c'est pour
toi il insiste prend la monnaie ont
pendant pardon je voulais pas d'offensé
et à une pièce là bas qui est capital
est tombé droite en plus importé change
prend prenez la madame tenez la mer vous
y avez vous andré caffin par exprès je
suis passé d'un fois je suis désolé du
temps elle fait exprès total 15 $ à on
prend pas les chèques au nom au nom
proposé chaud c'est chiant ça maintenant
c'est très sympa nadia tous remplis elle
même
à bientôt madame à les suivants aulas
lui c'est un homme occupé ces assassins
qui travaillent dur pour sa famille cela
bonjour monsieur que puis-je faire pour
vous es tu me parles même ça tu boxe
amateur ouvre toi
oui je t'en penses toi et je te fais ton
aux dogues mais pourquoi tu m'embrouille
quelle moto jean-michel là mais non mais
laisse aussi ça fait chier lui là il
arrive une embrouille tiens tu vois que
tu vois ce que je fais 9,6 vie je la
fait grossir il a fait grossir et je te
mets des petites tapes sur la joue avec
à la plus qu'en suivant ils sont deux
mais ça c'est des enfants ils vont voler
vite les caméras surveillance vite
ouais je vous à l'oeil alors qu'est ce
que tu veux une banane n'y a pas de
soucis aux plats
quoi d'autre ok donc elle vient de me
dire datant d'une minute pendant que le
talent comme il ya pas une caméra aux
toilettes elle veut pas du choc à ce
gars est un peu du sucre ses poteaux ces
poteaux
chacun est basse mais tu fais budget
mais tu fais put alors tant que je peux
mais c'est les ramasser mais le problème
c'est que là il ya de mieux en fait ok
avec toi fais attention à toi elle veut
du sucre où il ya du sud je sais pas
pour rien du su que je connais bien ici
sa chance et du succès ping stuff ça
c'est du sucre sa boîte va mourir
tiens il va c'est du sucre
ah si c'est ça c'est ça c'est bon elle
veut juste plein de sucre d'accord cette
meuf va devenir diabétique dans 5
minutes vraiment ouais t'es content
c'est bon tu le plus chez ces banques
est l'hôte est revenu de sa commission
alors ok je vous fait payer alors quoi
faire vous vous êtes des gros fdp dit
rien mais tu ne te sens bien
74 dollars s'il vous plaît il faut trois
glaces si ton fils était moins con je
t'aurais pas fait payer si cher
j'ai en suivant auquel gens mais de
retour menu principal on se réserve les
trois hommes étaient pour une prochaine
fois j'espère ça vous a pas attendu ce
cadre à la police que je fais pas être
là j'étais trouvait au moment où vous
amuser j'espère que vous a plu c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas les vidéos si vous
voulez plus d'htc weill [ __ ] c'est
vraiment génial
là dedans [ __ ] j'arrive à m'exprimer
ya un problème elle retourne dans ma vie
c'est de la merde si vous a plu ats deux
prochaines vidéos portez vous bien le
château monde pis
non
ans